welcome to Friday arees I'm in hotel
room yeah you'll find out by the end of
this you probably already know you guys
are smart little beautiful turds
anyway this happened
then this happened hello okay and now
we're petting oh I would apply a guy
he's like oh wait okay
and with pet and we pick oh I get sauces
here oh you'll meet a pig yeah no hi
guys I'm in my car going over to Hannah
Hart's place to celebrate her three year
anniversary of being on YouTube um and
after that we are going to film the
girlfriend tag because a lot of you have
requested it and by the time this video
goes up you'll have already seen it so
here are the moments before also it's
raining in Los Angeles which is new
that's like when that fluffy guy at your
work gets a haircut and you're like what
let's go to the wine strip oh I should
get an inch and then headed it up
there's a liquor store I'm gonna get
Hannah some champagne this happen hello
it just went for a long hike with Hannah
and goose and I didn't take any footage
is this count are you time here's a hike
so much you barked at every dog you were
kind of terrible punch it took you you
were took you and terrible you're like
one of those pretty girl gets away with
bad [ __ ] cook she's cute
ah this happened I'm doing a shoot with
Joe nation right now this is your
personal suffice here and then this is
happy yeah normal times its normal time
here's
now I'm in a car do I look like a badass
badass that probably gave you experience
and this I'm gross I just went for a run
but now that I'm gross I thought that I
might make a potentially bad choice I
don't know why but I woke up oh I wanted
to do this I think I'm gonna do it
I know goose I know I should it let's do
it the back this one okay
I was really I'm going to regret this
but it's just here and you're gonna
change color back to the color that you
probably wanted anyway relatively
quickly right okay let's just we're
committing we're doing it we're going
the color is on and now comes the wave
of instant regrets it's done I can't
tell I think it's okay it also kind of
looks green and this happen look at her
prance look at the price only does it
your pizza dance oh my gosh dude it's
nasty my god every week
yes favorite I get a little beans on the
fire now beans and I match a little bit
except my hair's kind of green what
about this hello yes I am in the same
clothes as last night um up well okay
good start
take two yes I'm in the same clothes
last night today we are going to South
by Southwest the music and interactive
digital the yada-yada festival in Austin
Texas which is one of my favorite cities
and I'm so excited to go um look who's
got a new collar Oh HollyRod a collar
yeah let's shoot were given by a group
of people
who took imodium we're gonna call uber
and get on the plane and go down to
Austin Texas for a couple days let's do
it
[Music]
we're doing a really great Angelina
Jolie's for a summation right now we
made it Boston right like here's our
view oh look at all those people
unsuspecting people oh it's just out the
front desk and the woman that was
checking me and she was like would you
like a map of downtown I was like no
she's like would you like and I was
already like no cue the minibar knows it
wait what yeah I want two key to the
minibar anecdote now I'm going to go
edit this video and post every guest
tomorrow
and if you're at South by Southwest
Tyler Oakley myself Andy Cohen and Zay
Frank are doing a panel tomorrow at 5
p.m. Austin time whatever that is in the
Convention Center also be on what's
trending at 2:30
Austin time and so those are the things
that are happening in my world and why
I'm down here and if you're around cool
see ya know
you
oh wait you guys I forgot to mention
it's big announced today that our second
special guest in our this might get
weird y'all show that mamrie and I are
doing the comedy show in Boston is whoa
Anthony I'm so excited I've never met
him before and the first time I'm going
to meet him is I'm going to force him to
go on stage and do ridiculous stuff with
us and so help you at the show so make
sure there's looks such a small amount
of tickets left by them now it's gonna
get weird y'all